allegedly Arnold schwarzeneger
intentionally farted in the face of one
of his co-stars Miriam marges is
probably best known for playing
Professor sprout in Harry Potter and
Juliet's nurse in Bas lerman's iconic
film Romeo and Juliet the British actor
told I've got news for you that she
didn't enjoy meeting schwarzeneger while
filming the horror movie end of days and
she hasn't gotten over it saying he's a
bit too full of himself I don't care for
him at all he's a republican which I
don't like he was actually quite rude he
farted in my face now I fart of course I
do but I don't F in bbl's faces he did
it deliberately right in my face